hey everyone how's it going my name is
miyuko and welcome back to my channel so
when i was getting my very first
software engineering job i had
no idea how the recruiting process
worked like i was just trying to get
that first job
and the whole process seemed like a
black box that i couldn't see through
whatsoever
once i entered the industry however i
started helping out with the recruiting
stuff like going to events and sitting
on interview panels and stuff like that
and it started just to make a lot more
sense to me like how all of it worked
and honestly after i was able to see how
things worked from the inside
i feel like ultimately for every job
after that i was just a much better
candidate because i knew how things
worked
and so i kind of figured it would be
really useful for a lot of y'all who are
trying to get that first job as software
engineers
to learn about how the recruiting
process works so i invited my friend
sarah who's the lead negotiator at
levels.fyi
and who also worked as a recruiter for
multiple fan companies to my show muko's
coroner to talk about the recruiting
process
i've had her on the show before and
we've talked about salary negotiation
but just her experiences are so valuable
because she
really knows the ins and outs of
recruiting and the do's and don'ts of
getting that first job
so in today's video i'm gonna share with
you highlights from that show
all about how the recruiting process
works everything from when the
recruiting season starts
to where companies decide to recruit
candidates from
and more so let's get started what does
a typical process
look like for a new grad to get a job
out of college
into the tech industry in term of flight
from a candidate perspective
it's going to be pretty similar to an
industry
recruiting where you're going to go
through the process of talking to your
recruiter
and then the first technical phone
interview and then the final round so
usually for some company
they like to kind of shrink it and only
have you talk to maybe
two to three software engineer and then
some company would want you to talk to
three to five engineer
now these interviewers are usually those
that just
volunteer to be an interviewer so these
interviewers that you talk to
from a new grad perspective or intern
they may not be
the people that you will be working with
in terms of like
the the process it tends to be a little
bit more
volume driven so for industry recruiting
usually what we look for is something
very specific like we need a backend
engineer who have experience with cloud
computing for example
versus for intern and new grad we
usually just call them as like fungible
engineer let's just hire them through
and then we'll figure out a team for
them after so a lot of it
is usually by cohort too so a lot of it
it's
almost like i mean the best way to
describe it is like batch hiring
when does like recruiting start for new
grads i guess so if someone was to
graduate
um in 2022 let's say what's the earliest
that companies are going to start
looking for to hire new grads yeah good
question so for a new grad an intern
the process start a lot sooner than when
like they actually open up the job
so usually for for amazon we do
operational
planning so we do operational planning
one and then operational
planning two so there's gonna be like
two times when we will review like head
count and things like that and budget
what does that look like
um and only certain team choose to
participate in
okay we want to have intern and some
teams can say hey we
don't have that capacity right now and
therefore we're not going to participate
and so for newgrad usually the hiring
process
already starts in january of the year
and the head count
they usually get head count from august
of the previous years already
the the process the head count planning
and all of that happens a lot sooner
than you expected
and so usually around this time and and
it sucks for a lot of folks who graduate
in december
when they don't when they start applying
and they don't see anything
and they just start to wonder like is
there something wrong with my resume
what do i need to do to kind of optimize
my chance and sometimes too like the
head count doesn't open until march or
june and then the interview process will
happen about like one or two months
and then you get your offer and then you
start in like around like
august so is it is it right then to kind
of
generalize that like each company kind
of has like
a number like they have like there's
this many seats open for new grads
and then so like you said like newgrad
uh
recruiting tends to be very volume based
where it's literally just like
interview as many people as you can from
different schools and try to fill those
seats is that kind of like a good
summary of how that works yeah so
there's like internship and there's also
co-op so for some company like microsoft
for example
um or even like facebook they have
specific recruiter to support certain
school
and then some company like for example
apple can choose to have a much longer
internship
or that's what called co-op where it can
be anywhere from six months to a year
and then there's only some company that
say you know we don't want to do that we
only want to do
like you know 12 weeks sort of like
program for
for intern um usually i would say like
stay on top
of that company internship program
because when we post a job we just get
so many applicants so
usually the job only stay up for about a
month and then after that we're going to
take them down
to process all of the applicants that we
have from from those pipelines
how do companies decide where to recruit
from
as far as like choosing which
universities yeah so usually they would
choose like top tech companies so for
example at microsoft they would have a
team of recruiter who only go after the
ivy league school
and then we have uh microsoft sometimes
would have like a team that go to like
top tech school like uc berkeley or
waterloo
um and you know it really depends and
usually
pay so much money to the school and
that's why they want that roi back
in their pocket yeah that makes sense it
like i think i get a lot of questions
about like
is it worth it to go to a four-year
university for computer science or
should i go to a boot camp
and ultimately one of the things that i
think is important to think about is
like what kind of connections does that
school have
because if you go to a school that has
those connections like if you go to uw
it's gonna have a connection to
microsoft because it's right there
if you go to stanford you're going to
have connections to basically every
uh tech company there is and so like
it's not just about i think the
education or the experience of going to
school but it's the network that you
gain
as a part of being able to go to that
school how does it work on the
recruiting side that like
we just general people normal people who
are trying to get a job into tech
that we don't know about like what's
something that you think is like a piece
of information that recruiters might all
know but yeah it's not common knowledge
out there
there's just a lot of different channel
for like sourcing candidates so
sometimes we don't just look through
like the people that apply
and sometimes it will take us to kind of
go out there and operate almost like a
headhunter
like to see like who's doing what and
you know which intern or new grad would
be good for a certain position like this
is more common for
um machine learning and ai just because
usually there's something specific that
we're looking for
the part that's i think that can can be
a little bit tricky
to navigate here is industry recruiting
is completely different than new grad
recruiting
and they're just a lot more that tape
being put around new grad and internship
so sometimes like the difficult part is
that we i just get so many messages from
students you know asking for
if they can take a look at my resume and
things like that and this
i can't do anything about it i don't
support the campus
and i don't have any visibility into
that even for at amazon
we have two completely applicant
tracking system
where one is our only intern and unless
if i support
intern that's the only way that i would
get access into it so i can't just
randomly submit
someone else's resume for
for that pod and that's something that
kind of like
sucks at the same time like as much as i
want to help this isn't anything that i
can do
so for those that you know maybe want to
reach out to a recruiter
be strategic about who you reaching out
to so instead of just going
on linkedin and just look for like
technical recruiter and send your resume
that way
don't do that do a little bit more of a
tailored search search for
campus recruiter search for a co-op
recruiter
search for like new grad recruiter
because you're probably will hear back
from those
recruiter um more than like a leadership
or like an industry recruiter
i think there's a lot of pressure to
have like a computer science degree to
get that software engineering job
uh most universities computer science is
an impacted major
which means that it's really really hard
to get into the programs and really
really hard to stay
in the program so there's just a lot of
pressure to like stay a computer science
student
um and i think there is a lot of just
like this notion that
if you don't graduate with a degree then
you won't be able to get that software
engineering role
um but what do you think about that from
a campus recruiting perspective
is it really important for there to be a
line that says bs computer science
yeah so i'm gonna get the phd out of the
way first because phd is something very
specific and usually they will require
you know that you have a computer
science or whatever it is that the
company really needs so
phd read your job description it will
say it's a requirement then therefore
you will need a computer science in
order to get that phd internship
or scholar program or full-time position
but for bachelor and master's degree if
you read the job description carefully
for the education
section they don't say you're required
to have a computer science usually a lot
of companies will say
computer science or stem or related
field
and when they say that a computer
science degree is not
required and actually in fact like from
i mean from my time working at amazon
and a few other
companies um the best engineer that we
have
actually didn't have a computer science
degree the best engineer that we have
came from degree like math especially
math
physics and some even came from more
like
education background or even like music
and those make really good software
engineer so you don't need a computer
science unless if
you're wanting to do something very
specific like machine learning and ai
then
you know the company can require that
but for bachelor master the answer is no
yeah the math physics education of music
majors it's just that like boggles my
mind because that's not
like when i was going to school i was
like that's not what i want a major one
major
computer only way to get a job but that
that's really
interesting from a campus recruiting
perspective like who's the one to make
the decision of
higher versus no higher if it's a little
bit like more abstracted
away from the teams yeah so this is kind
of like where it gets really tricky
because the manager that you talk to
that person may not be your manager when
you start that position
so usually i mean i'm speaking from like
amazon and i
specifically support amazon web services
we would just
kind of put the words out there in terms
of like hey
in recruiting we're trying to put
together a team
of you know interviewers like who would
want to participate so only a certain
manager would say
okay like i'm open to do this and then
only certain engineer that want to be a
part of it
um the nice thing about amazon is that
if you're trying to become a bar raiser
it does help kind of get your interview
accounts in
um because at amazon to be a broad razor
you need like a hundred
interviews to become one so like
sometimes like for the people that want
to get promoted
they would like want to volunteer to do
to do interview
in terms of like making a yes or no um
higher like decision each person
on the interview panel would have like a
rubric so let's say if
there's 300 viewers on your panel one
person would cover data structure and
algorithm
one person would cover object oriented
design and then maybe the manager would
be the one that do like cultural fit
and there would be like the checklist
that they go through that the candidate
do this
if they do let's say let's say this
candidate check seven
boxes out of ten that's a maybe and if
the candidate only checked one out of
ten okay that's a hard no
or if the candidate check eight out of
ten boxes
okay that's a yes and then usually we
would have a deep brief two where all of
the interviewers sit
in a room kind of talk about you know
that candidate
and performance and whether or not they
would be a good fit for the program or
the company
that's so fascinating that's like
totally separate from
how i thought canvas recruiting would
happen it's literally like it's very
rubric focused and it seems it's just
like some you're just trying to find
like a well-rounded engineer who has
like computer science fundamentals sarah
can new grads negotiate salaries when
they get their offer
for a new grad usually it's going to be
really hard because everything is again
operating we're operating from volume
here usually by cohorts just because of
you know pay quality we want to pay
everyone the same
for co-op usually there's a little bit
more of like flexibility
in term of negotiating but not much but
as a new grad
you do have the power to negotiate in
fact for some company like microsoft
they want to reward you for you know
going back to them
so if you had a previous internship with
them they will give you a higher
compensation package when you come back
to the company
thank you for sharing that thank you all
so much for watching until the very end
i hope it helped you to better
understand how the recruiting process
works
sarah of course has always shared so
many other amazing insights so you can
watch the live recording of the show on
mugo's corner by becoming a member today
by clicking the join button below and
you'll also be able to listen to the
audio recording of the show
through the mugos corner podcast and of
course the other way you can always
support me and my work is to subscribe
to this channel and share this video
with your friends
i'll see you next time and take care
everybody bye
you